[Music]
to our other top story questions
continue tonight on what led up to a
deadly shooting at a birthday party that
left a Legacy High School teenager dead
thank you for joining us at four I'm
Kirsten Joyce and I'm Brian Loftus now
that shooting happened at the Platinum
Hotel near coval and Flamingo Saturday
night Victoria Saha live from the high
school where the teen was a well-known
athlete
yeah from what I
part of the football team and part of
the track team I spoke to a few of his
friends off camera who tell me he always
encouraged his teammates to do better
a birthday party turns deadly near the
strip seventeen-year-old omorion Wilson
was shot on a fifth floor room of the
Platinum Hotel Metro Police say on
Saturday there was a party for an 18
year old as the night went on uninvited
guests showed up and there was an
argument that led to the shooting
according to the corner the bullet went
through omorion's chest he died at
Sunrise Hospital on Monday parents of
students at Legacy High were shocked to
hear what happened we just got to make
sure you know follow what kind of
friends they're around with you know
that's the main and who else is is in in
these uh in these parties and stuff it's
just that's why I got a little too
overprotected of my daughter she's the
only one and you know seeing that and I
would never you know expect that to
happen to anybody any other parents we
did receive a letter sent out by the
principal two parents informing them of
a student's death
I reached out to Clark County School
District police as well as Metro Police
to see if there was any reason that the
shooter could have been a student here
but I was told that this is an ongoing
investigation and that no arrests have
been made reporting live from Legacy
High tonight Victoria sahab 8 news now
Victoria thank you now the school did
point out that grief counselors are
available to students if they need them
some other parents telling Victoria
coaches were offering a safe space to
students to come talk to them